yeah so the problem with ozone is that
we were using these specific gases cfc's
chlorofluorocarbons in refrigerators
deodorants a small subset of of stuff
that we used and we got to the point
where there was just basically a basic
substitute you could just take the CFCs
out and put some in else in in its place
and initially it was maybe a little bit
more expensive but it was kind of a one
for one sub stitution within a really
small number of goods so once we did
that the problem was largely solved the
problem with climate change is like we
literally need to change everything we
need to change the way we produce energy
um the way we move around the food we
eat um the way we B stuff like it's full
economy wide problem so I think that's
part of the reason why it's so much
harder yeah what gives me you yeah so
how's it going what gives you hope
um we're still very far off track from
where we need to be but what gives me
optimism that we have a shot of actually
tackling this is we've actually made
quite a lot of progress in the last
decade it sounds unbelievable but we
actually have so we're currently on
track for around two and a half degrees
that's kind of the median estimate of
where our current policies are taking us
now that's very bad that's global
average temperatures relative to the
long run outage industrial where we're
going to end up I mean that's not where
we are now but that's where it looks
like we'll end up yeah by the end of the
century yeah and is that bad sorry sorry
to ask the dumb question is that is that
a problem that's bad that's really bad
MH um we've set targets of trying to
keep temperatures below
1.5° and well below 2 de if not we won't
reach the 1.5 degre Target we're going
to go past 1.5 degrees so in that regard
I'm not this like crazy Optimist um I
think if you'd asked me a decade ago I
would have said two two deg was
completely unfeasible as well I'm
becoming slightly more optimistic that
we can get close to that range although
we're currently headed for 2.5 yeah and
the reason for that and the reason I'm
optimistic and I think what maybe goes
slightly against the quote you gave
earlier is that I think if it was true a
decade ago that it was very expensive to
tackle climate change right if you look
at any of the Technologies we need to
switched to so solar or wind or electric
vehicles they were all far more
expensive than coal or gas or a petrol
car yeah so it really was like are you
willing to sacrifice the economy and put
put your money on the line in order to
solve this and a lot of countries just
weren't yeah I was talking to just for
context I was talking to shelling in
2005 he had been writing about this
problem since I think the
1970s and you know as as you say as of
2005 that's solar I mean solar is just a
pipe dream right it's yeah that's not
that's not a real option is it but now
it is yeah so over the last decade the
price of Solar has fallen by 90% the
price of wind has fallen by 70% electric
cars are starting to reach price parity
with a petrol car um so your solar and
wind are now the cheapest Technologies
we can we can put in instead of coal or
gas so I think regardless of climate
change many countries will actually just
start to do this because it's the
cheapest option so I think we need to
stop framing this as a are you willing
to sacrifice the economy in order to
solve climate change because I think
that's a false dichotomy and that's why
I'm a bit more optimistic now than I was
a decade ago yeah are you worried about
um solving the intermittency problem
because batteries I mean batteries are
got a lot cheaper but batteries don't
solve everything you know that the
classic you know what happens at you
know 5:30 in a December evening everyone
comes home Northern Hemisphere it's the
wind's not blowing the sun's not shining
it's cold
how how do you solve that problem with
you know without burning carbon so I
think that it's a big challenge but I
think it's a solvable problem um the the
the intermittency problem is different
on different time scales so for you know
evening out like Peaks throughout the
day on the basis of like hours batteries
work well for longer term storage you
might be looking at other options such
as hydrogen or we're now talking about
maybe methanol like storing it as a
liquid liid fuel which is is easier than
a battery over longer time periods um so
I think I think we will have a range of
solutions at different time scales in
order to balance that and then I think
that they are I think on the demand side
we'll actually just change things a lot
I think um like a problem you might see
is if we all move to electric vehicles
the problem you'll get is in the evening
everyone will come home they'll start
cooking they'll turn on the heating
they'll start charging the electric
vehicle I think what you're going to get
is a very different electricity system
where pricing will often operate and and
go with when Supply is highest so you
get really cheap electricity when the
sun is shining or the wind's blowing and
I think we'll actually start to adapt to
to that so you'll shift your electric
car charging to a time when it's not
Peak demand for
example